what are your thoughts on the safety and
efficacy of covered vaccines at the
individual and the societal level so for
the the vaccine safety data
it's it's actually challenging
to convey to the public how this is
normally done like normally you would do
this in the context of the trial you'd
have a law a long trial with large
numbers relatively large numbers of
people you'd follow them over a long
time and the trial will give you some
indication
of the safety of the vaccine and it did
um i mean but
you the the trial the way it was
constructed
when it was came out that it was
protective against covet it was no
longer ethical to have a placebo arm
and so that placebo arm is vaccinated
what large part of it
and so that meant that from the trial
you are not going to be able to get
data on the long-term safety profiles of
the vaccine
uh and also the other thing about trials
though there's tens of thousands of
people enrolled that's still not enough
to get when you
when you deploy a vaccine to the
population scale you're going to see
things that weren't in the trial
guaranteed
populations of people that weren't
represented well in the trial are going
to are going to be given the vaccine and
then that they're going to have things
that happen to them that you didn't
didn't anticipate
so
i wasn't surprised when people were a
little bit skeptical when the trial was
done about the safety profile just the
way the nature of the thing was going to
make it so that it was going to be hard
to get a complete picture from the
trials itself and the trials showed they
were pretty safe
and quite effective at preventing
both you from getting kovid actually i
think the main endpoint of the trial
itself was a symptomatic covet
right so um uh so that was like that was
you know i mean it was really um
to me like is about as amazing
achievement as anything organizing a
trial of that scale and running it so
quickly
and the final result being so
surprisingly high so good right
and um so
the but the problem then was
normally it would take a long time the
fda would tell pfizer to go back and try
it in this subgroup they'd work more on
dosing they do all all these kinds of
things
that kind of didn't we really didn't
have time for in the middle of a
pandemic right so you have a you have a
basis for approval that it's less
full than normally you would have for a
population scale vaccine
but the results were good the result
looked really good and actually i should
say for the most part that's been borne
out when we've given the vaccine at
scale in terms of protection against
severe disease
yeah all right so people who have got
the vaccine
um for a very long time after they've
had that for the full vaccination have
had great protection against going being
hospitalized and dying if they get
coveted let's separate because this
seems to be
there's critics of both categories but
different
kids and
kids and
old not older people like uh
let's say five years old and above or
something like they're 13 years old and
above so
uh for those it seems like the reduction
of uh the rate of fatalities and and
serious illness seems to be something
like 10x
i mean for older people it is a godsend
this vaccine it it transforms the
problem of focus protection from
something that's quite challenging
possible i believe but quite challenging
to something that's much much more
manageable because the vaccine in and of
itself when deployed in older
populations is a form of focus
protection
yes well by the way we'll talk about the
focus protection in one segment because
it's such a brilliant idea for this
pandemic of future pandemics i thought
the sociological psychological
discussion about the letter from francis
collins is um
because it was so recent it has been so
troubling to me so i'm glad we talked
about that first
but so the there seems to be
the vaccines work to reduce deaths
and that has the especially the most
transformative effects for the older so
can i let you give i've told you one
thing that i got wrong in the panic let
me tell you the second thing i got wrong
for sure in the pandemic
in january of la of this year
2021 i thought that the vaccines would
stop infection
yes right it would would make it so that
you were much less likely to be infected
at all
because the the antibodies that were
produced by the vaccines looked like
they were neutralizing antibodies that
would would essentially block you from
being infected at all
um
that turned out to be wrong
right so i think uh it and it became
clear as data came out from israel which
vaccinated very early that they were
seeing surges of infection even in a
very highly vaccinated population
that
that the vaccine does not stop infection
so you're a used car salesman and you're
selling the vaccine
and uh the features you thought of
vaccine would have i mean i have a
similar kind of sense when the vaccine
came out
vaccine would
reduce
uh if you somehow were able to get it
you would reduce rate of death and all
those kinds of things but it would also
reduce the chance of you
getting it and if you do get it the
chance that you're transmitting it to
somebody else
and it turns out that those latter two
things are not as uh definitive or in
fact or i mean i don't know to which
agree they're not i mean i think it's
it's a little complicated because i
think the first two or three months
after you're fully vaccinated after the
second dose
you have
60 70 efficacy peak against infection
yeah
so uh that which is pretty good i mean
right but by six seven eight months that
drops to 20
so some places some studies like there's
a study out of sweden suggested it might
even drop to zero but and then you're
also infectious for some period of time
if you do get it even though you're
vaccinated correct although there seems
to be
lucy data that the period of time your
infectious is short it's shorter but the
the the infectivity per day is about as
high so you still it's the point is that
that uh the vaccine might reduce some
risk of infecting others but it's not a
categorical difference
so uh a unvaccine it's not safe to be in
the presence of just vaccinated people
you can still get infected
you